among the rubble and derelict buildings
a splash of color to Mark the Muslim
holiday of idol fitter this makeshift
amusement park brings joy to these
children in the Syrian Rebel held town
of jinderis two months after a major
earthquake many were born into war but
for now they have a chance to forget
where they are
out fighting in the Democratic Republic
of Congo between m-23 Rebels and
government forces has led to millions of
people fleeing their homes many are now
living in refugee camps like this one in
Goma mesala Abdu is thankful to have
escaped with her life she says she gave
up celebrating the Eid holiday because
she didn't know where her next meal
would come from until now volunteers are
changing that by handing out food for
everyone here
we are happy because they brought us
food if by the grace of God the Feast of
Aid will take place then we will eat a
good meal to close this month of Ramadan
in joy
a shared hot meal of rice beans and fish
in the Gaza Strip streets and markets
are bustling but 17 years of blockade by
Israel has pushed prices up more than 80
percent of people here depend on Aid
according to the UN and while it's a
tradition to give to those in need and
wear new clothes many Shoppers say they
can't afford to buy each presents
I came to the market to buy Eid supplies
but unfortunately with the economic
environment and lockdown we can't afford
it despite the conditions we still have
to buy something
Afghanistan prayer provides some with a
Feeling
of and serenity nearly two years since
the Taliban took over the country is
facing sanctions Cuts in Aid insecurity
and a crippled economy millions of
Afghans are out of work or are being
paid much less than they once were but
for some the Eid holiday is helping
evoke a sense of appreciation for simple
things
some people say that there are economic
problems and there is no work and no
business but I'm driving taxis in the
city and I would say that contentment
and gratitude are important despite the
hardships they face people are coming
together sharing moments of happiness
and a respite from any troubles if only
for a short while rahila Muhammad Al
Jazeera
well Iran's supreme leader